all right alex
alex where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
i am from a beautiful country in north
africa
one of the oldest uh cultures and
civilizations
on earth what's it called
egypt egypt yes
and you uh you grew up with both your
parents
i grew up in a very
humble
stable happy home
strict uh rules
consequences uh you know and um
yeah
i had direction i had i had direction i
had good parents i have good parents how
would you describe your childhood
my childhood was spoiled
my childhood was very spoiled and um
when you're an adult and when you're
traveling around the world and you're
exposed to you know different uh
ways of life and and
and what have you
you start really realizing what you had
and and it shines a light on
on what you had and um
i
definitely think that i had a spoiled
childhood
uh and um i was very happy
i was uh very clean
um
and
well groomed i was like a well-groomed
type of uh
uh kid and uh i played professional
sports uh
i was encouraged to go into sports
healthy food um
so i would say i was spoiled
but uh
you came to the united states at what
time
i came to the united states in 1998
and i was about
16 or 17. so i came here straight to
high school a young virgin
yeah
the type of uh you know growing up in
the type of environment or culture where
if you ever even
kissed a girl like on the cheek before
you married her
then you're like you're like the
you know you're like
the man like you're the man like how did
you even get to do that like i'm so
jealous like you know what i mean like
you're you're i don't want to say pimp
but you're you know
you're that you're that you're the man
yeah yeah
so coming here so yeah i was coming i
was a virgin when i came here to high
school sophomore year high school talk
about let's talk about culture shock
yeah so figaro street must be a real
playground for you
for your figaro street oh my god oh my
god it's bigger it's just
oh man it's just the temptation is just
like
i don't even have the opportunity to
contemplate
you know what i mean growing up in that
environment coming here like uh missing
that and then
for example like
i came here virgin right like i
mentioned and then in high school next
thing like in high school
upstate new york
i go from virgin to oh tonight we're
having a party should come over because
this girl blah blah blah
is going to let us you know
do a train do a train on her
so talk about culture shock and the
sexual exposure
from nothing to
you know
i'm i'm in my head i'm like
i'm thinking it's a toys r us train like
we're gonna go play a train
you know like that like that's my
mentality at that age coming from that
country
next thing you know on a party kegs beer
weed everything and
and these girls these beautiful girls
you know uh
girls in my country are beautiful
gorgeous definitely
um they have the bod and the body adi
and all that right
but you come here and and it's a
different culture and the girls are a
lot more open and friendly and kissing
you and hugging you
so it's like
wow
this is this is nice
i want it you know
have you how old are you
i'm 38 38 you've been married or no i've
never been married and i've never even
really been in a serious relationship
that lasted more than a few months
um
and i think it's part of the thirst or
the uh
the curiosity with respect to what women
their body and and
uh you know their their actions in you
know in bed and compared to their
actions in the street
stuff like it's all very interesting and
uh
freaky do these interactions you have
with working girls
cause problems with your relationships
with with normal girls
absolutely not because because i mean
at the end of the day when you think
about it it's really very similar it's
very it's it's the same thing
but it's like the same
destination but you're taking like two
different roses so with one girl on the
street it's just a little more
straightforward and and down to the t
like this is what we're going to agree
on
um
and
we make an agreement we make another
like a verbal agreement basically
and it's a very short
very short relationship
but a satisfying one because she gets
what she wants i get what i want
and
the most satisfying thing about it is
the respect that
uh
you can is the respect that a man can
you know can carry the whole um
arrangement
uh
with
you feel for for a couple of hours or or
a day or whatever
you feel loved you feel loved
these girls are amazing like most you
know a lot of these girls they're
amazing they're like
they're like academy award winners
they're you know they're beautiful and
they're sexy and they're right and then
they're professionals professionals
thank you because once you really tell
them
because they ask you they know what to
ask their experience they know what to
ask these girls
literally are our
uh their job their full-time job is to
see how they can please the man
the way that he wants to whether it's a
fantasy whether it's reality
and they are able to accommodate him and
you know
so
how often will you
partake in this well i mean it's always
it's always linked with uh
with the euphoria and the
uh and the excitement of of drug use
right
especially cocaine for me
uh
you know if i sniff a couple of lines if
i smoke it if i snort it if i whatever i
don't shoot it but
when i start
[Music]
when i get that
desire to go do some drugs
immediately
immediately
all i want is a woman to share you know
what my like to
to basically yeah to share to share with
her what my body's feeling right now
with respect to
um just euphoria just euphoria and what
better than a beautiful woman
or or a good-hearted woman that's pretty
sexy a good-hearted sexy woman she
doesn't have to be beautiful co-bottle
no it's about the femininity for me
right it's about how feminine she is
how she talks softly and how uh uh
you know she's able to um
just just be a lady you know
that's you know that's what i go out and
look for
um
so yeah i mean drug use pretty much sets
it off
and then next thing you know you are um
you're in another world you just visited
another world with a complete stranger
that
somehow has the ability uh
to read you as a human being and and
just provide
exactly what you want
uh so it's a good escape
it's it's a very very nice escape are
you working currently
i'm i'm not currently i'm not uh i got
lazy with the whole uh covet
unemployment situation
i
speaking of spoiled
god bless america right
you know sitting there collecting a
check and
not having that many as a single man not
having that many responsibilities right
now in my life
uh
yeah things things
took a turn to the um so the government
is supporting you right now
as of right now no
the government is supporting you you
respect that i'm receiving
um
benefits through the um social services
yeah uh
associated
but you had jobs before this
yeah yeah oh yeah i'm getting a job oh
yeah of course how do you think i i
afforded like
like doing all this doing the drugs it's
expensive it gets expensive right yeah
cocaine's not cheap geez like a dinner
and a movie weekend with a nice girl
from
from the building that you work in can
turn into like
a 3 000 weekend right with a complete
stranger and
really good drugs and maybe a couple are
completely strange
so yeah i've had a job i've worked
i've i've done a couple of different
things this is one of the issues i have
right now coming out of kovitt actually
is that
i've done
many different things and now i've
gotten a chance to take a break and sit
there and really think about it so i'm
not sure where to head where to go from
here with respect to a career in a job
so i've been
stagnant
however
i'm blessed blessed
you've been doing this for how long how
many years
the drugs are in the women
uh both
um do they go to they go together well i
got well they they definitely go
together and i got introduced to cocaine
in um 2006.
so from 2006 up until literally covet
hit
uh
it was an occasional thing a weekend
thing a once every two three months
thing
uh uh it was an occasional thing do some
drugs
they call it relapse you know
do some drugs um
and
you know share share
share yourself
your emotions and everything with a
beautiful girl
last year it kind of escalated so
sitting around
and still having a decent income
obviously
it escalated it escalated i was out
there you know almost every other day is
that right because i was lost i was
sitting there lost you know when you're
busy when you're working you're more
you're you know
your your attention span to like
to your dreams and stuff like that is
a lot shorter and i don't mind right
it's celebration
yeah you're going to work you're focused
on work and then a couple days you know
a couple hours later you're focused on
what i'm having for dinner blah blah
blah but now sitting around with covert
you're thinking about everything and
you're like what the [ __ ] have i really
accomplished in
life
and you're saying thinking about that
and you're like bro this is too much let
me go get a couple of lines
and let me go talk to that girl with the
big booty over there that i saw the
other night
because i know what she's up to i know
what you're up to girl
if you had uh you've been robbed or had
had bad things happen to you no you've
been arrested or anything
um
i've been arrested before mother i have
i have charges in my i have a criminal
record but nothing not necessarily
nothing to do with prostitution yeah
right
no
how about diseases
no thank god no thank god
nothing yet
i'm very careful i'm very careful i'm
like i'm i'm very careful
and i always recommend to the young kids
too and and you know the people that are
not
uh practicing the way i do
i'm very careful i always
try to make sure that and i'm real i
keep it real because there's nothing
better than that right i keep it real
like listen when's the last time you got
tested sweetheart like uh uh
you know uh uh
would you like to go take a shower
before we
before we do anything um
have you ever been exposed do you use
condoms regularly i'm going to use a
condom i never done i've never eaten you
know you're not going to get the answer
that's necessarily the truth yeah but
you can but yeah
you're going to get the answer that they
know that you want to hear sure sure
sure however you can tell
you can tell you can read you can read
people right okay you can you can read
people
and uh if somebody's you know
you can tell when somebody's lying you
tell you can tell when they're running
game because they have more game than
these these girls have more games these
girls are hustlers these girls are
hustling and they have there's many
different there's many different flavors
of hustling yeah i've learned
some of them are very like they come
across as really honest and sweet and
nice as
can be oh yeah and they're stone cold
hustlers oh yeah and other ones look
like
are you kidding me oh my god is those
the ones those are the ones you have to
worry about they're very dangerous those
are because those are the smart ones
because those are you know extremely
smart
girls they come up to you and and you
feel like that's your cousin or
something
they're good at getting money yeah yeah
you feel i mean because these days it's
so easy to dress well these days right
these days clothes are everywhere and
especially out in these stores because
of the internet they're so cheap
so a homeless girl
that hasn't showered for three weeks and
all she does is drugs and and sex and
and a girl that has just let it go right
can
suddenly today
wake up out of wherever she was
go to
any one of these clearance stores even
even uh forever 21.
but a lot of them boost right a lot of
them steal this stuff anyway
but but it's easy to get it these it's
easy to to dress nice these days a girl
right that girl that three week shower
can come out on the street looking like
looking like your cousin looking like an
actress a model we're in hollywood right
like we're in l.a
you walk wow so are you are you an
actress are you
that's how they look it's easy to dress
well so yeah
and they play the part perfectly
but next thing you know about an hour
later and
a little too much drugs in your system
and alcohol
you're literally sitting there
sometimes fearing for your life
sometimes fearing for your life or
having that
that adrenaline and like you know how
when that adrenaline rushes through you
and your arm here stand up and you just
feel that chill
uh like so you know what i mean i get
that a lot i get that a lot and it's
usually from the girls that look really
nice
sound sophisticated educated
um
they know how to play the game
you ever develop feelings for any of
these girls
there's always feelings involved because
i'm a hypocrite
and
i'm a hypocrite
one part of me one half of me is like oh
sweetheart how did you end up like this
you're my sister baby come here let me
let me just get your hotel i don't even
want to [ __ ] let me just get you a hotel
room let me let me help you take care of
yourself and get the [ __ ] off these
streets for a minute baby how did you
end up here sweetheart that's one half
of me the other half of me is like
i really want to hit that right now real
you know
beautiful girl and
the way you talk
i know you're going to make me feel so
happy
and sexually uh satisfied
like i i want you i want i want you i
want you bad
so there's always feelings but love with
respect to love like
no i've never felt that before
i've never felt that and i don't allow
myself to that's why
because i know that one day i want to go
back home to get married for back home
you know when you think you can go back
home and get married after this party
you've been living
you'd be surprised what's going on back
home these days
we went from we went from
18 19 year old virgins to
there's like
sex and sex addiction
therapy right now in egypt really in my
country yeah do you think humans are
meant to be monogamous
absolutely absolutely but but also
humans humans i mean we are
wild we're freaky we can get you know
come on i mean
look at porn today look at porn these
days
you know i don't but but i've heard you
don't watch porn i know i've heard i've
heard stories there okay i interview
some of the girls that do this
guys but uh they do porn that sounds
horrible oh my god the [ __ ] that they do
these days is just crazy so of course
we're freaky we're very sexual we're
horny and horny with a capital h-o-r-n-y
[Music]
right and uh yeah but i think that we
have also been giving the ability to
to
control
our horniness and our emotions
just like anything else just like
somebody that quit smoking cigarettes or
smoking savers he has the ability and
willpower to stop it if he wants to
drugs i mean
so
yeah i mean
it's interesting
you seem you don't seem unhappy you seem
pretty level-headed
and happy and able to communicate
honestly life is short
life is short and
i believe that when a person speaks
he should speak the truth because
there can be so much
taught and learned from
somebody's real experiences
and um and i think you know kids these
days
need to hear the truth and and what's
real and what's not because i i think
it's a very very different very wild
world we're living in today like the
porn that's out there today uh it's
everything is just you know
developed and and uh
developed extremely i think since since
i was a kid
you know when when i was a kid there was
um in egypt
my city is a very small city i don't
want to say it no this time around
but um
there was like one vhs
cassette porn porn video
and it was like the only one in the
whole city everybody knows each other
there's like four or five schools you
know what i mean and we all like kind of
hang out we have competitions and stuff
like that together everybody kind of
knows everybody is like
dude it could be somebody living from
the
other edge of the city
and you ask like yo where is where is
where's the tape everybody's talking
about
i had to be like oh it's with the sam or
hassan and you would know who it is like
it's that small you know what i mean
it's kind of like everybody kind of
knows everything oh who the [ __ ] is it
you know that guy that goes to this
school he was blah blah blah known for
this no for that uh his family does this
and you're like oh man and you're like
ready to go to this house to get that
tape so it was very today you're like
pornhub and all these like sites it's
like jesus and and not just the sites
but the things they show on the side
yeah that one cassette that was going
around my city it was like a super old
italian movie like you can't even see
anything because of all the pubes like
like you know like the girls the females
and the males all this pubic hair you
can't really see [ __ ] you know like it
was very different
very different
yeah it's a different world now isn't
it's in it it's changing fast it's a
different world today so i think
that and it's loose right so i think
that people deserve to hear the truth
especially the younger generations
uh
and
i would like i'm not in a position to
give advice to anybody or whatever and i
am a hypocrite when i do give advice
like i mentioned and that's real
um
that's why you know i like i like to
people hearing
the things that my prac my safe
practices
and the fact that life is short if
you're gonna do something do it be happy
about it
otherwise don't do it if you feel like
you if you feel like you're doing
something and you're like hesitating and
you're like oh this is so wrong i'm but
i'm gonna feel like [ __ ] after don't do
it
don't do it don't live your life you
know oh my god ptsd and this and that
and how and because then you're just
setting yourself up to like live and
regret the past right if you if you want
to do something do it
don't listen to society don't put all
this [ __ ] in your head
follow your heart like you you feel this
girl is beautiful she's kind blah blah
blah
you know
experiment
experiment experiment but be happy about
it do you do you have any guilt or
remorse after you have these
i mean coming i mean
yeah i i do i do it's always there
because i was raised in a very strict
like muslim country right
uh so yeah sometimes of course i feel a
little guilty there's always that you
know voice in the back of my head
uh
you know with the um
um there's always that voice in my head
trying to
um
you know tell me that oh this is wrong
this is right this is wrong you know
what i mean all these rules
and stuff
but i always as an adult now and as a as
a
very experienced adult because i've i've
lived many different lives i have
experience in you know whether it's
mainstream like working professionally
or doing criminal things in the street
or being with women or you know uh
i've i've done i have experience in a
lot of different things
and
i feel like um
yeah just be happy about what you do
be happy about what you do don't listen
to all this
[ __ ] that's in your head
okay have fun with it life is short have
fun with it
learn something from it be careful
safety first
and move on with your life
that's how i feel about it
a little bit of guilt happens in my in
my body and my heart just because of
where i was raised
and the you know
and the strictness and suffering right
yeah
all right alex thank you so much for
sharing your story and being so honest
thank you for having me thank you very
much all right
oh my god you were great come on you
were great
you